tell me why someone should feel safe
going to space in this ball well that's
I say that's actually an excellent
question so with with without driving
spacecraft you really try to do
everything possible to make the
astronauts safe I mean if there's
somebody something if something think of
something better to do I'd love to hear
it but so I'll tell you some about some
important differences of fraggin
compared to prior spacecraft or even
compared to the Soyuz which is quite a
reliable vehicle first of all the super
Draco engines the you can see these
thrusters that are side mounted into the
if the spacecraft there are eight of
them they provide a redundant escape
system so if something goes wrong with
the rocket these thrusters fire and pull
the astronauts away from the rocket and
in fact since there are eight of these
engines they can actually be multiple
engine failures and still the escape
system will work and there's also a
parachutes for yes and then so if if you
go even beyond that and say let's say
the entrance is a total propulsion
system failure
we actually have we're done ever done a
parachute system on board with with dual
drugs and and and three main chutes I
mean it's like ridiculously I mean from
a design standpoint I'm not sure what
more one could do you've got like
multiple engines multiple parachutes
I mean space is a dangerous thing it's
not something that you know humans
didn't evolve to sort of be spaceflight
you know varying creatures but in as
much as as one can make certain design
decisions to make a spacecraft safe we
have endeavored to make those decisions
and I'm at a loss to think of anything
more that we could do and if we can
think of something more we'll do it how
confident do you pee on this competition
for this contract but you are going to
prevail I don't want to be complacent I
don't be complacent or presumptuous
about the contract I think we've done
everything we can to have this be a good
design and I think we've shown to to
NASA who's been in in an awesome
supporter of SpaceX in the past frankly
we wouldn't we wouldn't be where we are
today without without NASA I think I
think we've shown that we can do a good
job and hopefully that's that makes
difference for this competition
remember members of Congress here who
are looking to you in this company being
an American company yeah it's going to
be a huge advantage isn't it just to
have that sort of congressional support
well I actually does I mean the national
competition really will be Independence
of anything of any congressional
influence my experience with us is is
that there really are it's very
objective frankly if that if NASA wasn't
so objective then we would not have won
any of our earlier contracts because we
would have been out lobbied by the big
aerospace companies who have Paul more
resources than we do the reason I wanted
to bring drag into Washington DC was
it's really to show the key congressmen
where US tax balls will be going at the
other day they all they are the ones
controlling the purse strings for a
competition in general so they're not
deciding the winners but they are
deciding is the amount of money
allocated to
a commercial human spaceflight program
is it going to be well-spent doesn't
have a chance of success because a lot
of people who think that space you know
human spaceflight should not be allowed
in the commercial sector I mean it's
sort of an odd odd position I think but
there's still a lot of people who feel
that way so you know Congress needs you
know they need to think okay well you
know if this money this taxpayer money
is spent does it seem like we would have
a good outcome and you know and seeing
it in person is just a lot more
convincing than seeing it on paper my
don't question for you and I were
talking about this earlier you're taking
on some very big players here in
Washington can you win this one I don't
know I don't know if we would in the
long term I have faith in the American
system of government and I and I think I
think I think I think in the long term I
think we've got a we've got a good shot
the short to medium term or much it's
much harder just it's much harder to say
where things are going the short to
medium term and of course in order to
get to long so we better get through the
short to medium term I just find it odd
that we have to fight so hard just just
for there to be competition for national
security launches it just doesn't seem
right